ja wir sind bei unserem buschfunk und
die ärgert mich ein bisschen weil wir
immer so früh anfangen zu arbeiten
können wir leider nicht gucken oder
können wir nicht gucken aber müssen wir
ja gar nicht bild buschfunk erfahren sie
alles was gestern abend passiert es im
dschungel und wir geben direkt rüber zu
janina kirsch die ein stargast hat ja
[Musik]
sechs geständnisse trennungs lügen
second fieber und eine ehekrise drei
tage dschungel liegen hinter uns und ich
sage es ihnen es ging schon ordentlich
rund im busch und damit herzlich
willkommen zum bild buschung natascha
ochsenknecht es heute bei mir war im
dschungel im jahr 2018 möchte ich und du
verfolgst jetzt ganz genau das geschehen
in südafrika hat was er damals in
australien genau sagt mir was war dein
highlight dein moment des landes das ist
natürlich der glück lange also der
letzte biss in die hosen runter habe ich
aber auch nichts anderes von ihm
erwartet weil es ist natürlich ein typ
der sehr präsent in der öffentlichkeit
der funkelt und macht und tut hat aber
eine sehr verletzliche seele ich denke
das hat er uns die letzten jahre immer
wieder so stückchenweise gezeigt dass er
da irgendwie schwere kindheit hatte und
für mich war klar denn der da reingeht
der wird die hosen runterlassen er wird
leiden er wird reden lassen und er kommt
der hipster drüber tränen hat er
gelassen ein pompöses tränenmeer gab es
am wochenende von harald glööckler warum
das soll uns jetzt noch einmal anschauen
in meiner
was 70 geburten 3
projekt google haben
[Musik]
wenn du natürlich ebenso denkt was du
immer kränker
letztendlich ist es ist
60 mit dem anbieter
[Musik]
das ist natürlich schwierig wenn man
einen
[Musik]
findet hause den dann
und damit geht das schmetterling ein
[Musik]
ein eingehender schmetterling der ganz
offensichtlich große eheprobleme hat
natascha das geht einem ans herz wenn
man das hört für mich klingt das
wirklich aber so als würde er darüber
nachdenken sich von seinem lohn zu
können mit dem er seit 35 jahren
zusammen ist und auch schon einige jahre
verheiratet er sagt ja selber ersten
reihen wollt ihr letztes jahr schon war
er schon eine prognose ich gehe ich muss
mir über einiges klar werden und man
merkt auch die wahnsinnige traurigkeit
man hat das gefühl hat eigentlich
niemand mit dem man reden kann und das
hat sich dann öffnet ist natürlich auch
so eine sache weil bekommt ja dann auch
jeder mit und ich glaube auch dass er
kurz davor ist zu überlegen ob man
absprung macht weil er selber meint er
ist ihnen gefangen ist alles toxisch und
man sieht ja es tut ihm nicht gut wir
haben mit hcm angesprochen ich würde dir
gerne zeigen was er zu der ja
offenbarung seines mannes gesagt hat
ich war überrascht was hat nicht
betreffen sagte ich werde alles zuerst
mit ihm besprechen wenn er wieder nach
wenn er wieder zu hause ist und
da ist noch ein zitat
wir haben immer zusammengehalten in
guten wie in schlechten zeiten wir
werden auch jetzt alles was anfällt
verlesen natascha erlösen das klingt für
mich so ein bisschen wie eine trennung
vorbereiten und die dinge sind passieren
wer das für dich in frage gekommen so
eine emotionale weichte gefunden mit
deinem partner spricht während oder im
dschungel sitzt und das ist nicht
vielleicht auch ein bisschen unfair ich
würde sagen wir werden vorher schon
genug gesprochen haben das hat sich
anscheinend ja dann nichts irgendwie so
geändert dass harald gesagt okay ich bin
da jetzt rein und dann gucken wir mal
danach wie es aussieht ich hoffe einfach
dass jetzt hat man vielleicht auch sagt
der das auf einmal realisiert wie ernst
dies halt einfach ist das die große
probleme haben weil oft ist ja ja lass
den mal reden dann wird das schon wieder
und wenn das aber einer entfernten sagt
und der partner ihnen auch noch sie
dabei wie traurig er ist und wie die
tränen darum kann ich mir schon
vorstellen vielleicht legt sich ja dann
deiner doch ein schalter um das man ihm
sagt okay wir versuchen eine andere
basis aufzubauen wir reden und jetzt
packen dass beide zusammen an
wir wünschen es ihnen auf jeden fall
dass sie beiden ist hinbekommen lasst
uns mal einmal übers eck kennen fieber
sprechen ja das selbsternannte nein
moment ich wollte jetzt gerade sagen
teppich luca aber teppich luder dürfen
wir janina user führen jetzt gar nicht
mehr nennen weil sie hat ja ganz klar
gestellt ich hatte gar nicht mit dieter
bohlens ex im teppichladen von der
schneidet es war der zu schneidetisch
genau ihre zuschauer jahrelang hat sich
dieses jahr dieses mysterium in der welt
gehalten teppich oder sollten die nicht
mehr teppichen oder nein aber wir machen
ist jetzt hier einen knall aus dem ruder
da sucht schneider das ist auch eine
schöne schöne schöne bezeichnung auf
jeden fall gab es da ein streit um einen
feldbett was filipovic haben wollte sie
wollte ihm nicht geben denn sie wurde
von einer zecke gebissen und hatte dann
fieber husten fieber und dann ging es
ordentlich zur sache so wie sich das
gehört im dschungel
alter ich hab gerade zeiten fieber
war es geht nicht in einen schwarzen
herrenrad nein aber ich hoffe nicht aber
ich nicht mit mir reden lieben spitzen
dass ich auch gar nicht
[Musik]
ok
hallo hallo okay es war so ich bin heute
morgen aufgewacht und hat denn es hätte
hier in den wein also dachte ich mir
schlecht na ja da habe ich mich ja
irgendwie versucht zu beruhigen und dann
wurde mir die theke rausgezogen und ich
kann das nicht
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
zecken fieber vielleicht lieber er
sollten wir vielleicht erzähle lieber
sagen oder 10 4 ist uns alles dabei aber
es ist natürlich klar so langsam fängt
es an das essen wird weniger emotionen
kochen hoch dann wird diskutiert dann
sagt er eine du bist du schreist dabei
schreit er selber irgendwann die sinne
werden irgendwie verändert sich
natürlich dann auch ne oder so eine
zecke ist auch nicht lustig kann ich
selber schon es wirklich nicht lustig
wenn du weißt du der kopf könnte jetzt
mal drin beim haben die kreativität
rieber filipovic ist auch eigentlich hat
er nicht so dass gemacht da nicht so den
eindruck als wäre er so auf krawall
gebürstet aber ist dann ja doch jemand
der auch gerne seine meinung sagte was
ist was hältst du von dem er hat schon
temperament der ist ja sehr unterhaltsam
aber auch bei ihm habe ich gesagt der
wird jetzt auch nicht 24 stunden den
clown machen der ist er ein hotel wir
machen jetzt im spiel und so das kennt
man ja am anfang wir sind eine große
familie genau du bist genau wüssten zwei
tagen informiert am 15 und gewonnen ich
glaube der bei dem muss man aufpassen
wer kann dann schon ein bisschen hoch
gelegene rakete das wird spannend aber
die beiden das ist wird das thema glaube
ich auch ein bisschen behalten es gibt
ja auch schon so ein bisschen
grüppchenbildung also man sieht der nina
josef jahren zusammen mit glöckler und
anuschka und dann das greenteam tara und
philipp ja ständig setzt sie auf seinem
schoß und sucht auch total hinein mir
wichtig ist dass das man da so eine
bezugsperson hat und glaubst du denn das
oder findest du also man hat das gefühl
sie hat mehr interesse an ihm als er wer
wird bei ihr ist es ja so ist in allen
formaten so unterwegs ist wundert mich
auch dass die sachen um das gar nicht
gewohnt so beobachtet zu werden die es
in jedem format muss sie beobachtet wird
und in jedem format ist sie auch immer
versuchte sich ein tor aus wo sie sich
wo sie dann so an doch wie eine kleine
zettel könnte man fast aussagen und ich
glaube ja natürlich ist es schön da
jemand zu haben mit dem man plaudern
kann brückler wenn sie und janina muss
man ein bisschen aufpassen der glück man
muss aufpassen nicht zu sehr in die
letzte rolle verfällt das geht ganz
schnell und dann hat er noch zwei
richtige daneben die dann auch
vielleicht auch darauf einsteigen ja
ansonsten bin ich ja jede für gespannt
weil die anderen
wir müssen nochmal einmal über eine
person reden die nachgerückt ist und 2
jasmin hätten sie sollte eigentlich
nicht ins camp jetzt ist sie da habt
gleich an tag eins eine bombe platzen
lassen rund ging's um ihren verstorbenen
ehemann willi und um ihre liebe und sie
sagte tatsächlich dass sie eigentlich
nie von willi getrennt badewonne noch
mal eben kurz reinhören denn das hat
ordentlich für zündstoff gesorgt
ja scheinbar viel technik technische
probleme sondern hier sehen können
bilder abgelaufenen will als wir das
letzte mal gesagt hat meine wohnung leer
geräumt wurden dachte ich oh mein gott
der arme es gibt zwei seiten die einen
sagen dass es so sie sagt jetzt sagst
ist so ich finde schwierig willi ist da
oben dem dies wahrscheinlich jetzt
besser als vorher da war und so viel
stress und es war natürlich klar dass
sie irgendwas erzählen wird denke ich
mal die familie ist jetzt nicht gerade
besonders ab da wird man wenn er raus
kommt der film tut er ja gescheppert
soll es ja schon haben sie hat ja auch
erzählt dass es ziemlich einen bösen
streit gab dass sie angeblich
entführt wurde oder in eine wohnung
gelockt wurde und dann soll sie
verprügelt worden sein das ist natürlich
alles sehr mit vorsicht zu genießen weil
du auch sehr wichtig es gehören immer
zwei parteien dazu komischerweise hat
jasmin herren uns wenige wochen nach dem
tod von willy ein interview gegeben und
ich kann dir verraten da klang das mit
der trennung auch noch ein bisschen
anders würden uns das gerne mal
anschauen und ihnen zeigen was jasmin
herren gesagt hat als sie bei uns im
bild interview über den tod ihres mannes
gesprochen hat und auch über die
trennung
wiedersehen wollte auch nach der food
truck eröffnung direkt zu mir kommen
wir hatten vor gemeinsam in urlaub zu
fahren um dort eben
[Musik]
gemeinsam wieder zueinander zu finden
zueinander finden das klingt irgendwie
nicht nach trennung also diese
geschichte hat sie widerspricht sich das
wieder nicht ist wieder richtig jetzt
gerade und ich habe das interview damals
ausgesehen und ganz ehrlich ist jetzt
auch immer wieder diese wilde
geschichten hoch komme ich finde es sehr
traurig weil irgendwann sollte man die
toten ruhen lassen es ändert ja nicht ob
wir zusammen waren oder nicht zusammen
waren oder ob sie sich angenähert haben
letztendlich doch schnuppe es ist leider
vorbei und von daher denke ich mir dann
konzentriere mich jetzt auf meine
karriere was du vorhast oder so aber
irgendwann ist auch mal gut
ich finde das ein bisschen problematisch
wenn jemand so unwahrheiten aktie und
man das gefühl hatte man hatte ja auch
das gefühl im camp glauben ihr dass
viele nicht so richtig und haben auch
wirklich kritisch nachgefragt was meinst
du wie geht ihre reise jetzt da weiter
ich denke sie muss jetzt aufpassen weil
sie natürlich auch weiß dass sie dadurch
schlagzeilen gekommen und dass sie dann
natürlich auch automatisch komplett
nochmal den diese familien schießt es
ist ein schmaler grat also wenn sie
jetzt mehr solche dinge auspackt sind
doch ein paar am start die dann am
lagerfeuer wird sozusagen er ganz
ehrlich wir auf der mitgliederliste
ziemlich mehr hören weil irgendwie haben
wir auch mal ganz andere sachen gehört
die welt ist ja kleine wir haben
tatsächlich auch mit bekannten mit einem
freund von willi herren gesprochen will
ich wollte ja noch einen reibekuchen
truck eröffnen haben da ein
geschäftspartner der dass mit ihnen
zusammen gemacht hat und der bezweifelt
die aussagen die jasmin herren da im
dschungelcamp getätigt hat auch stark
ich hoffe er ist jetzt zugeschaltet in
der leitung denn eigentlich wollten wir
ihnen hier heute auch im dschungelcamp
begrüßen jörg hansen
hallo
guten morgen
das waren jetzt wirklich ereignisreiche
tage auch das was mir erzählt hat
darüber haben wir gerade schon
gesprochen wie es ihre einschätzung zu
dieser situation also ein zu der
situation dass sie sagt dass die
trennung luge fake war und sie nie von
willi getrennt war und zum anderen
natürlich auch die schwere vorwürfe
gegenüber der familie ja ich meine
natürlich hoffen wir gerade junge firmen
auch sehr gespannt an und ja auch das
was da erzählt haben wir jetzt natürlich
bilden verfolgen können und ja es ist
einfach sprachlos ist wieder zu sehen
bekommen haben gerade die informationen
die sie halt am lagerfeuer ausgelassen
hatte
meine frau war geschäftsführerin des
fußballs gewesen und haben es dann halt
wie die auch sehr sehr nah und allein
schon diese geschichten nehmen dass
siege vorgehabt hätten nach der
schlussglocke einfach so
man muss sich auch mal überlegen wir
haben den fußball gemacht meine frau war
geschäftsführerin der 55.000 euro
investiert alleine wenn das wahr gewesen
wäre von jasmin einfach hinzunehmen
damit wäre das natürlich schon
charakters sind wir natürlich unter
aller sau wäre aber haben es auch dazu
sagen ich kannte sie sehr sehr gut und
hätte es niemals gemacht dass er hatte
alleine seine seine tochter seinen sohn
hierzu sehr geliebt als dass er
überhaupt irgendwo auch nur ansatzweise
daran gedacht hätten einfache bauern die
wahren kölsche jung gewesen immer wenn
der baum und im feld gewesen ist dann
war seine dringendsten nach köln zu
gehen also von daher wissen sachen die
kann man halt absolut aus dafür lege ich
meine hand ins feuer
natürlich da ist dann muss man sich
etwas zu erzählen haben aber wir haben
uns eigentlich schon vor geraumer zeit
vorgenommen dazu gar nichts sagen aber
wenn man dann halt solche wichtig die
halt so krass erfunden sind dann finde
ich auch dann sollten wir einfach auch
mal die andere seite hören und ich denke
das ist richtig kann nicht mehr raus
nehmen sie heute auch mal für die zu
sprechen
jansen was genau hat willi herren ihm
denn wirklich jetzt konkret über seinen
beziehungsstatus damals gesagt waren sie
getrennt sie waren definitiv getrennt
gewesen das weiß ich ich habe das damals
auch alles angeleiert zusammen mit
seinen kindern zusammen mit seinem die
schüler dass er halte an weltkrieg wo er
halt die scheidung dann halt
durchbringen kann und wie gesagt das ist
alles vollkommen klar wir haben
unheimlich viel mitgekriegt wir haben
fast jeden tag zusammen gesessen waren
natürlich auch zu dem zeitpunkt noch
sehr gut mit jasmin gewesen und von
daher haben wir wirklich sehr sehr viel
mitgekriegt da bin ich jetzt auch gar
nicht ins detail gehen wir haben aussage
kriegt wenn sie uns angerufen hat mit
meiner frau stundenlang telefoniert hat
also von daher wird wissen das schon so
einiges was wir halt nicht an die
öffentlichkeit bringen wollen aber es
ist definitiv fakt
wir haben die ganzen schreiben vom
anwalt hier und auch damit kann man
belegen das ist definitiv kein fake war
unsere geschichten aufzutischen man geht
jetzt zum anwalt man lässt da irgendwie
ein fake scheidungs schreiben aufsetzen
und sowas das ist doch totaler
schwachsinn wer ganz ehrlich wer würde
denn denn so viel geld ausgeben und saic
schreiben auszugehen ganz einfach
entweder man trennt sich oder man trennt
sich nicht die beziehung der beiden war
halt einfach toxisch gewesen die zwei
haben sich beliebten die zwei haben sich
gehasst aber am ende hat es hat einfach
nicht gereicht um glücklich zu ende zu
gehen er kann so vielen vielen dank am
ende können wir natürlich auch nur sagen
dass das was zwischen den beiden waren
ende nun die nur die beiden wissen und
eine person ist leider davon nicht mehr
unter uns vielen dank dass sie sich dazu
geschaltet haben und alle die
eine sache die ich ja am dschungelcamp
immer liebe ist twitter denn in der
netzgemeinde geht es immer so was von
abda kommen die lustigsten kommentare
über die kandidaten
und deswegen haben wir die top 5 der
besten tweets im social web für sie
zusammengefasst
so der junge läuft und die netzgemeinde
ldi geht mal so richtig steil kein
format sorgt für so viele fiese tweet
wie das dschungelcamp unter dem hashtag
ebase für ich bin ein star hagel nur so
hämische kommentare dieses mal bekommt
es kandidatin linda so richtig dicke ab
hier die top five sind die sich bei
diesen shootings eigentlich sicherheit
dass diese linda lady nicht die
eigentliche prüfung ist ja man kann die
gedanken niemandem verübeln denn linda
entpuppt sich zu ober kratzbürste in
camp ein anderer user ist sich sicher
linders superkraft neben ihr wird die
manson family friedfertig und
sympathisch wenn auch das tut weh und
damit noch nicht genug es wird gemotzt
und wieder gemotze an da musst du nur
die anstrengende linda daneben sitzen
und prompt janina sympathisch ja ich
gebe zu die beiden werden wohl niemals
freundinnen zum schluss wird die
dschungelprüfung der ober zicke wie
folgt zusammengefasst ich sehe nicht ich
sehe nichts sehen nichts ich sehe nichts
ich sehe nichts ich sehe nichts sehen
nichts ich sie nicht ich sehe nichts
wir sehen hier ganz gut uns eindeutig
dass linda sehr im fokus der
netzgemeinde war die war aber auch echt
wahnsinnig anstrengend gestern oder erst
beschwert sie sich die ganze zeit über
jeden und alles und dann macht sie die
krasseste muse in dieser prüfung aber es
ist ja immer so sie beim bachelor schon
so also sie will die ganze zeit
aufmerksamkeit für mich ist das schon
richtung geliftet und sie kann sehr gut
manipulieren das heißt sie entschuldigt
sich und dann bums haus am main drauf
also eher zuckerbrot und peitsche
das ist ja immer so die größte dicke
lips die dicke lippe riskieren irgendwie
dass die zählern alles ein also die
liefern gar nicht ab also die liefert
nur damit ab dass sie irgendwie ich
zeigt wie schlecht sie drauf ist wie sie
eben die leute an greift die ganze zeit
und sie hört ja nicht auf sie lässt sich
auch gar nicht sagen wie lässt sich
nicht sagen und ich persönlich finde die
rauch super super anstrengend ich mag
dass sich wenn man sich wo andere
gestellt und ich mag das auch nicht wenn
man dann ebenso manipulativ unterwegs
wie sie das gemacht ja und sie und
janina werden definitiv keine freunde
mehr mir tut janina neben ihr auch immer
ein bisschen leid weil man muss er sagen
in der prüfung
die hat es versucht so gut es geht zu
meier viel hat die hatten am liefert die
wahl ruhig der gesagt komm der zwar auch
am ende nichts mehr gesehen aber linda
einfach gar nichts gebacken gekriegt und
wie du sagst sich über andere lustig zu
machen über andere zu meckern dann
selber aber nicht abliefert nicht schön
und da hätte ich auch ehrlich gesagt von
mir ein bisschen mehr
ein bisschen mehr rückgrat erwartet und
er fand ich nehme mir ist überhaupt gar
kein rückgrat geht nur wenn man schon
allein die frage gestellt bekommt was
findest am schönsten im dschungel ich
dann wollten wir schon wieder hase läuft
und dass sie sagt hier war schon mal
mein handtuch nähe ich mache keine wache
ich wünsche mir dass ein mann der
richtige ansage gemacht und vielleicht
sind ja dann auch mal die fassaden weil
so wie sie tot glaube die ganze zeit
dass sie weiß alles die weiß gar nicht
mehr sie denkt wahrscheinlich noch das
einzige playboy bunny da drin und die
schönste aller zeiten da haben die
anderen mädels das aber schon mal auf
das abgelieferten und aber mal oben
drauf ja ob linda sich noch einfängt und
vielleicht doch noch ein bisschen
stärker in den prüfungen zeigt das
werden wir auf jeden fall heute abend
sehen denn da ist sie wieder dran in der
dschungelprüfung dieses mal muss sie ja
etwas in den mund nehmen und dann am
besten auch schlucken insofern sind wir
geschmacks ganz andere und
vermutlich danke dir ja sehr gern
hallo hallo hallo und willkommen im
buschfunk ja ein pompöses tränenmeer hat
dem südafrikanischen dschungel am
wochenende geflutet und die tränen sie
kommen ausgerechnet aus den eutern von
harald glööckler über den emotionalen
ausbruch des selbsternannten gillitzer
königs sprechen tanja may und ich gleich
aber erst einmal wollen wir uns
anschauen warum harald glöckler am
wochenende zum trauerkloß wurde
einplanen
die herzen meinen
was 70 geworden drei tippten
googelt haben
[Musik]
ja
wenn du natürlich eben unser denken dass
du immer kränker
letztendlich ist als es ist
60 punkte hat der mann weiter
[Musik]
das ist natürlich schwierig wenn man
einen
[Musik]
findet hause den dann
und damit geht er erst später ein
[Musik]
da hätte man dem harald glöckler am
liebsten einen taschentuch gereicht
tanja wie geht es dir damit würden und
diese szenen schiesst er weinend im
dschungel klagen darüber dass eine ehe
scheinbar nicht so läuft wie sie laufen
sollte ich war sehr überrascht dass ich
das gesehen habe weil er harald
glööckler ist ein sehr positiver mensch
wir haben ja auch mehrfach gesprochen
bevor er ins dschungelcamp gereist ist
und auch noch als er schon in südafrika
war und er hat sich so gefreut und dass
diese szenen jetzt kommen zumal er sich
ja auch solche gedanken gemacht hat um
seinen ehemann um den herrn stroh den er
zu hause zurück lassen musste weil er
eben nicht gesund ist und er hat es ja
ganz ganz fantastisch organisiert also
dass herrscht nicht alleine ist und ganz
liebevoll über sie gerade angesprochen
wir haben den ausschnitt aus diesem
artikel den werther damals gemacht haben
vorliegen da war es ja wirklich so dass
er sich sehr besorgt ja gezeigt hat und
sein ehemann und dafür gesorgt hat dass
er wirklich versorgt wird auch zu hause
erklärt nochmal einmal bitte ganz kurz
das damals mit denen gesprochen was hat
denn der mann von hartley eigentlich
daher schroth der iss hat diabetes und
er ist trotzdem was ja auch hat wird er
jetzt erzählt hat er ist natürlich
wahnsinnig gern süßigkeiten es ist ja
nicht unbedingt toll wenn du diabetes
hass und er hat auch depressionen er hat
auch starke rückenprobleme bewegt sich
natürlich dadurch nicht mehr und was ja
so ein teufelskreis ist also wenn du
denkst okay ich habe schmerzen bleibst
du nur noch sitzen oder liegen und dann
bringt sie am ende auch wirklich gar
nichts und deswegen hat sich der arbeit
glückler ganz arge sorgen gemacht und
hat also organisiert dass immer jemand
da ist der für den kopf werfen aufpasst
wenn er irgendwas braucht denn quasi die
fernbedienung reicht da hin zum arzt
fährt und die sind auch eigentlich am
herzen eine seele die beiden so klang
das für mich jetzt aber gerade nicht so
er hat er ganz klar gesagt er ist in den
dschungel gegangen weil er eine auszeit
brauchte weil er sich auf gedanken
machen muss er hat von einem
schmetterling gesprochen der eingesperrt
wird und wenn ein schmetterling 1
gesperrt wird kann er nicht mehr fliegen
und das damit meinte er sich selbst also
er fühlt sich in seiner ehre fassung das
sind schon extrem
harte worte ja er sagt ja auch dass der
herr schroth inzwischen sehr
misstrauisch geworden ist niemandem mehr
traut und deswegen möchte auch nicht
dass da harald glööckler das haus
verlässt und das geht natürlich mit
jemandem charakter nicht der lebt ja vom
publikum der brauch applaus und wenn du
so jemanden einsperrt dann ist genau das
jetzt was wir hier erleben im
dschungelcamp dass er scheinbar tief
unglücklich ist damit aber natürlich
darf man nicht vergessen die beiden sind
seit 35 jahren ein paar also beruflich
wie privat die leben zusammen und die
haben ja auch eine richtige familie sich
aufgebaut der herr schroth hat töchter
der war einmal verheiratet bevor er sich
in den harald glöckler verliebt hat die
haben also töchter und die haben auch
enkelkinder das ist ein schönes
familienleben aber scheinbar doch nicht
ganz so glücklich wie man dachte so und
jetzt stellen wir uns mal alle vor du
schickst ein ehemann in den dschungel
und denkt so ich setzte mich jetzt heute
abend da hin und guckt das und alles ist
gut und ich feuere ihn an
und dann siehst du wie dein ehemann vor
den augen vor ganz fernsehdeutschland
erzählt wie scheiße diese ehe läuft du
hast mit dem ehemann von hat gesprochen
wir wollen uns die zitate einmal
gemeinsam anschauen
er sagt ich war überrascht was hat mich
betreffend sagte ich werde alles zuerst
mit ihnen besprechen wenn er wieder zu
hause ist und dann kommt aber noch ein
überraschendes statement und zwar
folgendes
wir haben immer zusammengehalten in
guten wie in schlechten zeiten wir
werden auch jetzt alles was anfällt
verlesen tanja fair lösen das klingt für
mich ein bisschen wie wenn er nach hause
kommt dann werden wir unsere werden wir
darüber reden und dann werden wir die
sachen sondieren und irgendwie gucken
wie wir uns am besten fair und
harmonisch
separieren interpretiert du das auch so
also im ersten moment denkt man okay der
redet jetzt von einer trennung die
bevorsteht ich persönlich glaube nicht
dass die sich trennen wie gesagt es ist
eine lebensgemeinschaft also ich glaube
nicht dass weder rot noch herr glööckler
leben kann ohne den anderen die sind
seit 35 jahren das darf man nicht
vergessen ein paar beispiele ist ja auch
ein paar jahre älter als der glückler
und ja das ist so ein fels in der
brandung das ist seine familie ein leben
und deswegen also ich find's ganz ganz
schlimm wenn die beiden sich zu ändern
und ich kann es mir auch nicht
vorstellen aber man merkte schon er war
traurig gestern und er war auch sehr
überrascht dass der harald glööckler
dass über ihn gesagt hat also ich wäre
auch traurig für mich klingt das schon
wirklich wie die vorbereitung zu einer
trennung aber es gibt noch einen anderen
beziehungsstatus der etwas ungeklärt ist
über den gesprächen müssen jasmin herren
jasmin henn hat gleich am ersten tag
losgelegt im dschungel und hat natürlich
über ihren verstorbenen mann willi
gesprochen und hat da etwas erzählt was
mich doch sehr überrascht hat und zwar
hat sie behauptet sie war nie von willi
getrennt er wir wollen in diese aussage
bitte noch einmal reinhören weil die hat
für ganz schön viel zündstoff gesorgt
ich wurde gedroht innerhalb meiner
eigenen wohnung
es gab immer menschen die versucht haben
uns auseinander zu bringen oder uns
nicht zuzulassen
weil ich angeblich schuld war dass wir
irgendwelche substanzen nimmt ja also
ich bitte euch das ist krass ja dann gab
es noch einen weiteren vorfall mit einer
körperverletzung
und von der person nicht gedroht hat
richtig hektisch habt ihr mir getan ja
verprügelt
mehrere personen haben mich verprügelt
dann habe ich ihm gesagt pass auf ich
habe eine idee
jedoch zum scheidungsanwalt
setzen schreiben
aufnehmen die milch zum zum anwalt und
ganz einfach dann wirst du denn dann
denken die wir sind getrennt und dann
machst du deine reibekuchen und fragt
nach auch im hause ab dann ist das thema
erledigt dann ist zwar polen offen aber
wir sind zusammen lass uns abhauen aber
immer gesagt irgendwann haben wir ab
dazu ist leider nicht mehr gekommen
da also angeblich war die trennung mit
willi nur gefragt waren gar nicht
getrennt alles war nur inszeniert wir
haben mit jasmin wochen nach dem tod von
willi herren gesprochen und da klang das
ehrlicherweise noch ein bisschen anders
wenn sie mal wir wollten uns wiedersehen
er wollte auch nach der food truck
eröffnung direkt zu mir kommen wir
hatten vor gemeinsam in den urlaub zu
fahren um dort eben
[Musik]
ja
gemeinsam wieder zueinander zu finden
wieder zueinander finden kann ja das
klingt irgendwie so als hätte sich die
geschichte im laufe des letzten halben
jahres von wir wollten es noch mal
miteinander probieren und wir waren sie
getrennt die geschichte hat sich
irgendwie verändert glaubst du ja also
ich glaube ihr nicht weil jetzt sieht
man es ist natürlich immer einfach
irgendwas zu erzählen wenn der mann um
den es geht leider gar nicht mehr unter
uns ist und wie du selbst sagt sie hat
ja auch mit bild mehrfach schon
gesprochen darüber dass sie getrennt
waren dass sie sich wieder annähern
wollten jetzt auf einer sagt sie im
dschungel was natürlich auch gut klingt
dass sie nie getrennt waren und das ist
nur für die öffentlichkeit war die haben
wir gestern noch mit einem der engsten
freunde von willi herren gesprochen der
natürlich auch sagt totaler quatsch
stimmt nicht die waren definitiv
getrennt und eine sache noch auch die
sachen die sie sagt über die familie sie
wurde verprügelt auch da haben wir ja
mit freunden und bekannten gesprochen
die auch sagen dass es so ein schlechtes
verhältnis und am ende des tages gehören
da immer zwei personen also zwei
parteien dazu auf diese aussagen muss
man sehr mit vorsicht genießen oder also
dass die kinder von willi und jasmin
sich überhaupt nicht mochten das ist
bekannt das haben wir ja auch mehrfach
berichtet dass die so aufeinander her
gegangen sind also dass sie sich
wirklich geprügelt haben fällt mir auch
schwer zu glauben vor allem wenn ich
verprügelt werde und zwar mehrfach und
auch mit vorsatz dann gehe ich
irgendwann zur polizei und zeigte an